est ce bientôt la reprise des spectacles
cette annonce très attendue de la
ministre de la culture roselyne bachelot
qui est tombée hier des concerts test
avec expertises scientifiques vont être
organisées il va y en avoir deux une à
marseille dans la salle du dom ou mille
personnes seront présentes et puis une à
paris dans la salle
accor et 20 ou entre 3000 et 5000
personnes seront présentes et ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que même les
individus testés positifs à la kobe 19
avant le concert participeront à cette
expérimentation le 17 octobre 2018
il est donc ici à votre place et nous
revenons sur ces faits avec les images
de l'émission quotidien l'interview est
animée mais jean-luc mélenchon a pu
s'expliquer il est calme en sortant du
studio depuis cent sur les anticorps
monoclonaux serait-il la clé d'un
traitement contre la copie de 19
l'agencé européenne du médicament a tout
juste entamée l'évaluation de ces
molécules
mais l'allemagne en a d'ores et déjà
commandé 200 mille doses aux états unis
seul pays en produire pour le moment je
ne veux pas croire
adrien cas tenaces les oules ils ne
seraient que j'ai fini en un an je finis
je ne voudrais pas croire qu'il ne
serait qu'un censeurs qui au lieu d'être
utile à ses idées se voudrait avant tout
important
vous voyez dans les caves de ce quartier
là les quelques nous attrape il nous
ramène dans l'est kabyle nous mettre des
cas vous voyez c'est à dire on obligé de
répondre d'une manière ou d'une autre
nom peut pas répondre dans les frappes
en faisant quoi qu'il soit
on sait la solution qu'on a au nom leur
tire dessus au mortier et c'est gentil
emprunt vous avez reçues d'autres sens
unique mois à cette table depuis la
dernière fois que jean luc mélenchon et
vie mais vous choisissez aujourd'hui
pour une raison qui m'échappe pour
régler vos comptes avec lui par mon
intermédiaire je veux dire une chose et
numéro deux du parti mais vous dire une
chose je règle aucun compte
d'accord tout le monde l'aura compris
nord moi mais c'est extrêmement choquant
c'est d'égal à égal
donc les voyous sont légales des
policiers des policiers donc ce sont des
affrontements dégâts légalement nous ne
sommes pas dans des affrontements d'égal
à égal
je ne crois pas avoir vu d'autres et
interview de monsieur jean jacques
bourdin ou vous interrompez la
discussion que votre invité pour montrer
des images depuis lors
jean luc mélenchon s'est dit ben
finalement avec jean jacques bourdin je
suis traité comme parfois avec d'autres
bien sûr il ya des moments où il faut
ces contrôles enfin quand il ya une
atteinte à l'ordre public quand il ya un
comportement suspect quant à une
réquisition de la part du procureur bien
sûr il faut des contrôles
bien sûr qu'il faut la présence de la
police dans les quartiers
mais ça ne veut pas dire contrôler
l'identité en permanence un certain
nombre de français et dont j'ai fait
partie au 2e tour à la présidentielle
ont voté manuel macron pour faire
rempart à madame le pen est aujourd'hui
je considère que ce n'est pas un rempart
c'est une passerelle c'est une
passerelle et ça c'est la responsabilité
du gouvernement que de suivre l'agenda
de l'extrême droite et que de vouloir
mettre en scène ce duel qui finit par
être un duo on peut pas reprocher aux
policiers aux gendarmes qu interviennent
toujours dans les moments difficiles
toujours dans des moments difficiles de
prendre sur eux tout ce que la société
avant n'a pas su faire ni les parents
dans la serrurerie c'est des gamins de
12 13 14 ans qui ont des barres de fer
dans la rue est ce la faute des
policiers
non c'est plutôt de la faute à mon avis
du manque d'autorité parentale du défaut
d'intégration de laponie au peuplement
qui concentrent les difficultés tu as tu
regardes mondialement la dictature est
partout sauf dans un tout petit canton
de l'univers qu'on appelle l'europe et
encore c'est bien que les haines
démocratie kandel
l'europe nous n'allons l'est pas
vraiment nos médias ne sont pas libres
non non vous dresser un tableau assez
sombre et célèbre canaux d'amsterdam
pour le plus grand bonheur des patineurs
amateurs ce monsieur n'avait pas
vraiment forts qui ont gardé tous les
observateurs extérieurs ils le disent la
france et dans les derniers dans dans
les classements des démocraties en
termes de liberté des médias
ccc pas manquer lycée est scellée qu'en
observant et je comprends vous vous
sourciller à ce que je dis mais je
sourcing